everybody Sean McGinnis here with the GS
News Update
watch out America Lindsay Lohan is on
the loose
legally speaking but her lawyers are on
the loose Lindsay Lohan's fine she's
fine back in July she claimed that GTA 5
s minor character lacy Jonas was an
unequivocal reference to her take-two
interactive rock stars parent company
maintains that Jonas and Lohan are
similar only as far as they are both
young blonde women this week however
Lohan's legal team provided 67 pages of
complaints pictures and reasons she
believes she's entitled to some
financial gain from gta5 according to
the complaint Rockstar used this 2007
photo of Lohan as well as hiring a
look-alike model to really capture that
essence of Lindsay Lohan her legal team
is also claiming that the blonde woman
who was used in gta5 marketing material
who by the way is not Laci Jonas was
created as a reference to Lohan many
people have seen this image of Kate
Upton practically being traced to form
this drawing so the connection with
Lohan is really a bit of a stretch in
addition Lohan argues that gta5 does not
represent transformative use of her
likeness which is protected under the
First Amendment because Rockstar was
interested in financial gain above all
else financial gain huh let's ring a
bell wasn't there some news story
recently about someone trying to
desperately sue a company for financial
gain I don't know maybe it's just a
coincidence GameSpot user Kristi
underscore said in the comments if she
wins I'll sue Hideo Kojima my dad looks
like the old Solid Snake for more on GTA
5 and our brand new all Lindsay Lohan
news all the time hub come on back to
GameSpot calm may have been lying about
when those things
[Music]